this is sal with jeffrey morgan what are
we going to do now we have this is an
unfamiliar environment for me what's
going on here what is this
so we're in a word processor because
we're going to talk about words word
processor yes fascinating what word
processor are we in by the way this is
uh this is google docs google drive i
think is now called everyone could use
this attachment okay all right so if
you're gonna write you're gonna you're
gonna actually write on a keyboard so we
thought okay let's get out of let's get
out of this handwritten stuff and let's
get into a real keyboarding word so i
thought today we're gonna talk about
nouns all right nouns i remember that
okay
so you know so nouns is actually a
grammatical term uh the the really key
idea behind nouns is naming things
grammatical like like subject predicate
all these crazy things adverbs adverbs
conjunctions you know but but nouns are
about naming things you're taking a
strong stand against my entire education
yes
and actually naming a noun in a more
understandable way by calling it
something that names things exactly and
the power of a noun is
so why would i need a new noun so if i
had the word dog why do i need the word
cat
and the answer is because cats don't
come when they call when you call dogs
do right there's a difference between so
now i need the words dog and cat so so
do i need the word cocker spaniel well
maybe not if if if i'm just a dog owner
but if i'm a if i'm a pet store owner i
need the word cocker spaniel i'm not
typing cocker spaniel because actually
you wouldn't know how to speak about it
spaniel sort of like spanish only was it
no yeah yeah okay the spaniel part is
the easy part i thought maybe cocker had
an agent or something you're doing good
cocker's manual so
we haven't gotten to that yet but that's
but you're getting hung up on grammar
which everybody does i shouldn't have
capitalized dog and cat though so
but you're you're i'm getting hung up on
grammar you are getting about grams i
want to be a member of the ruling class
exactly so at least look like what's
funny this is this is how people can put
roblox in the in their writing because
they worry about grammar before they
worry about logic we're i want to talk
about the logic which is why or the why
does people care about a cocker spaniel
what a pet store guy does because you
know you might not people come in and
they specifically want to buy a breed of
dog and so and and cocker spaniel has
certain actions gives you precision it
gives you precision it does and what you
notice about people is when they have an
area of expertise they have lots and
lots and lots of precise nouns in that
area sometimes they call it jargon yes
it's okay so jargon is just a bunch of
nouns for special jargon itself is a
noun
there it is and it all comes back no and
what's interesting about it so look at
the word jargon why do you need the word
jargon because it gives you power over
the world it lets you identify a class
of language and say you know what that
language i don't need to understand
those specialists need to understand it
because they're nerds in that subject
but i don't need to or maybe i should
but i'm also going to tell them to stop
using it well because we're preventing
other people from understanding and the
issue with jargon is jargon doesn't
prevent specialists from understanding
each other in fact it probably helps
specialists but it prevents generally
because we can get to precision faster
exactly exactly so when you hang out in
silicon valley with all these software
people and they're always using three
three-letter acronyms and you're going
well what's crm spt whatever it is it's
like okay but they know what they're
talking about
so that's all i would want to say about
now and says look you want to know you
want to know a bunch of general nouns to
work to sort of work your way through
the world so there's a set of there's a
set of vocabulary you just have to know
to be a citizen
and then whatever you're passionate
about you should expect to get more and
more nouns in that area because they're
going to teach you the refined
distinctions that make that area
interesting and make you more powerful
in that specialized area what i think
would be a fun way to end this yeah is
to just list a bunch of rounds okay and
maybe things that are not nouns okay all
right so so you you want to just
brainstorm and we'll brainstorm go ahead
you go
you go first all right
chuck norris is a noun chuck norris yes
chuck norris is is some would argue he's
maybe a verb and a noun well an
adjective
but he's definitely a noun
this is a noun and basically the what
you're doing though is you're saying
he's a body of forces yes the
interesting thing about nouns is they
always represent a body of forces that's
why we care about them so you know water
has the property of cooling and tables
have the property of holding things up
and cups keep waters on tables and you
know i mean the when your
nouns help you model how the world works
and so if you don't have enough nouns
you might not know how it works and but
after a while you don't need more nouns
unless you've seen some new property in
the world that you're trying to name
love love okay so now love is an
abstract now that's one of those ones
where it's not a concrete noun you can't
hold it it's not a person place or thing
i mean i guess you could call it a thing
but it's really it's a relationship
and but it's powerful and if you don't
understand love you have trouble you
know when you go home at night yes irony
okay ooh so irony is an interesting word
so irony is but now who needs to know
the word irony which i think i think
it's alanis morissette uh isn't ironic
but most of her song is it's actually
it's isn't it unfortunate
a guy who's never ridden on a plane and
the plane goes that's unfortunate that
wasn't so iron that wasn't iron i guess
there's a little bit of irony there well
but there's there's kind of yeah there's
sort of irony at one level is two
perspectives which don't link up
but but but irony as a concept is
especially i would argue it's a
specialist world most people
probably don't need the word irony but a
literary critic could not live without
it yeah and so again it's it's what are
you interested in i mean if you're
interested in hockey you know you'll get
there or soccer or golf i'll do golf
because i love golf so so you know you
need to know things about like a high
fade well what's a high fade well it's
it's a shot in golf or a flap shot or
you know what's a lob wedge or you know
that kind of stuff i threw swimming and
golfing there because they'll sound like
an action they are but they're when you
talk about the action itself you can
make you're naming the action so
swimming is good for you i i want to
take swimming well swimming lessons
that's actually it's modifying the word
lessons but but
languages are very various sometimes yes
language is a very very mutable thing
words can be verbs modifiers nouns
um
and it's amazing when you try to teach a
computer these rules
we still can't do it yeah but but kids
learn it before their love is sometimes
a noun yes sometimes a noun sometimes is
sometimes a verb exactly
and when you're talking about it as a
noun it means you're talking about the
force of love when you're using it as a
verb you're talking about your
relationship being in a relationship of
love to another person so verbs connect
nouns to each other so john loves mary
right so now we've connected we used a
verb to connect two nouns together
um i'm also listing not nouns not nouns
yeah so so eat run uh yeah lovely
yeah so basically what you're gonna find
with the not nouns there's gonna be
three other classes but
the action all the action stuff then all
the modifier stuff so is a modifier it's
it's telling you jane is lovely or
that's a lovely day out so these are eat
and runner actions that's right if we
were to use the grammatical fancy words
verbs absolutely lovely as a modifier
right so it could be
it could if it's modifying if it's
describing a noun it would be an
adjective that's right if it's
describing a verb it would be an adverb
right learned i learned those are good
but that that's the grammatical idea
yeah i don't want to okay with those out
of my whole world
well that's the difference between
semantics and syntaxes sometimes the
words use but from a meaning point of
view yeah and you need modifiers only to
the degree that you want to be more
precise about
what's going on in the world or you want
to be more rhetorical you want to
actually create a bond with with your
audience by using a modifier to connect
with them emotionally those are the two
classic reasons to use float is a verb
it it's it describes an attribute of
ivory soap uh that is not an attribute
of dialysis i think i think you're
dating people because i barely remember
those guys that was apparently their
their biggest claim to fame is that the
soap floats it floats it's amazing that
that marketers determined that people
would buy soap based on the fact that it
would slow it floats i think actually
they found out
i think what happens they probably did
focus scripts to say you know the cool
thing about this soap is it floats
which to me tells me they put air in it
i'm getting less soap but i don't know
but you see you're big that now you're
going the wrong way
it's too much logic
exactly that's exactly true
so so born okay so again
born is is an action it's also uh you
can use a modifier i was
born in born in portland oregon so that
tells me stuff like that he was born
that would be modified he was it's a
state
yes it's an intransitive verb it's a
state i mean so this is this is where
the grammatical categories get very
confusing and very complex and i
actually don't like teaching grammar
until people are well into their writing
world because it really doesn't help
right um what does help is these four
ideas name things that's the noun like
stuff
talk about actions and relationships
that's the verb-like stuff be more
precise about either one of those that's
the modifier stuff and the fourth one we
haven't talked about is where it's like
and but although when they're called
conjunctions and that's about how do you
learn all right i'm here because we're
just saying not nouns we're throwing
everything so i put in and when
what when although exactly yes cool ways
of talking about how two ideas are
heretofore therefore moreover
and then one thing there's one class of
grammar people should just know about
all the prepositions in out above around
whatever it turns out that they're
always using used in a modifying way so
you you never use in by itself it's like
the boy in the car and in the car just
tells you more precisely something about
the boy into yeah exactly above around
of
yeah uh no no as it can act that's
actually a little as a little
grammatical blurp it's it's it's not a
noun no it's it's it's an it's a it's
actually a form of modifier but it's not
a noun no it's not complicated yeah
that's true it's not enough no that's
why we're talking about the website yeah
you're right you're right you're right
yeah you're totally very cool well this
was fun we should do one of these i like
these